[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
patron
c'est un bon feu
s'ils passent par là on va bien du kram
et le second bâtard
[Musique]
et
tantôt jamais pu blairer noël déjà tout
petit c'est passage lui écrivait au gros
barbu je crois que mes lettres il disait
pas c'est bien celle qui confondent et
nintendo et stu et d'opci je crois ce
battage peut dire que je ferai pas de
cadeau j'ai grandi cette année me
demande pas si j'étais ça je suis
toujours pas caser maintenant je suis au
chômage j'ai la phobie des reines et
j'ai bien des luttes au vert les bons
sentiments de ma grand mère j'ai vomi
dans divers chacun essaie
bassil 3 voire avant bientôt reprendre
un sapin avant la fin du mois de travail
jugées pas comment du vélo calendrier de
l'avent moi je viens d'acheter 24
tellement je suis impatient j'avoue j'ai
trop la flemme je me prend dans la
veille au soir nous réjouit déjà de
faire la queue des heures durant dans un
magasin blindés finalement j'arrive trop
tard pour la barbie putafranges combats
près de six ans
[Musique]
oh
c'est
[Musique]
non
cette année encore on va chez des
inconnus
il pense comme durs à plateaux de la
rubrique c'est la famille à moi je les
avais pas reconnu la prochaine fois que
je m'apprête confessions intimes je
manquerais ras-le-bol du saumon
chocolat de la dinde fourrée au père
héros envie de vomir qu'on va la crèche
changement
sous les rois mages en plus que les
mêmes par bonnie chang et melchior
balthazar et harry potter je sais je
suis nul en crèche mais je fais des
efforts je vais souvent de la langue le
nom du bébé qui dort lui offrir des
cadeaux n'a jamais été mon fort je suis
donc allé recevoir et encore
c'est pour moi non qu'est ce que c'est
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est un cadeau
c'est surprise c'est une surprise
c'était un hamster
pour manger c'est cadeau pourri
c'est jodie mon chéri mais celui-ci est
finie super grand frère un nouveau radio
réveil je vais faire comme l'année
dernière je range dans ma campagne
[Musique]
c'est assez simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les dangers
la mère nawal pour les super noël amer
mais le mercure est basse et gêne vous
voulez voir mr freeze
est coupée
samantha tu passeras la compta avant de
partir
oui au fait j'ai un petit qu'eux
vous pouvez télécharger gratuitement le
mp3 de la chanson sur pv nova points
comme slash noël et puis vous pouvez
voir toutes mes autres vidéos sur
cyprien point fr bref je vous souhaite
pas un joyeux noël
[Musique]